- [Voiceover] Hi. My name is Jen,
and I help create the SAT.
The new SAT is made up
of two main sections:
Math, and evidence based
reading and writing.
And the evidence based
reading and writing section
is made up of two tests.
The Reading Test, and the
Writing and Language Test.
In this video, I'm going to
tell you about the Writing
and Language Test.
I'll go over what this section
tests, and how it's laid out.
Then, I'll tell you about
how the section is scored.
First, let's go over what
the section aims to assess.
The SAT Writing and Language
Test is designed to assess
how well you can revise and edit texts,
which we'll call passages,
about a range of academic
and career related topics.
The questions associated with the passages
will put you in the role of
someone revising and editing
the work of an unspecified writer.
Questions will ask you to
improve the development,
organization, and use of
language in the passages.
And to make sure that the
passages follow conventions
of standard written English
grammar, usage, and punctuation.
The types of questions you'll be answering
have been carefully designed
to help you demonstrate
the literacy skills that are
keys to success in college
and careers.
Now let's go over what
you can expect to see
on the Writing and Language Test.
You will see four passages with
eleven questions associated
with each passage.
You will have 35 minutes
to read the passages,
and to complete the questions.
There will be one passage each
on a career related topic,
history/social studies,
humanities,
and science.
These for passages will
vary in their text mode.
At least one will be argumentative,
at least one will be
informative/explanatory,
and one will be nonfiction narrative.
You should also expect to see
a range of text complexity,
from ninth grade on up to
the first year in college,
or post-secondary training.
Some passages, and sometimes
some questions, on the writing
and language test, include
one or more tables, graphs,
or charts, that relate to
the topic of the passage.
For example, a graph may
provide additional support
for a point made in a passage.
Questions may ask you to use
information from the graphic
to correct a factual error in the passage,
or to replace the
passage's vague description
with a more precise one
using specific numbers.
You'll never have to make
corrections to the graphic itself.
All of this passage variety
allows you the chance to show
how you can apply your
revising and editing skills
across a wide range of
topics and purposes.
OK. Now let's talk about what
the Writing and Language Test
looks like, and how it works.
When you open a test booklet,
you will see the passages
on the left, with the title in bold,
and the questions on the right.
The questions will appear next
to the part of the passage
to which they are anchored.
Sometimes, a passage may
extend to more than one page,
so don't assume the passage is over
until you see the bold
title of a new passage.
The boxed question numbers in the passage
will also help you determine
the place in the passage
that the question is targeting.
Keep in mind that many of the
questions rely on the context
of the passage, so you may have to read
more than the sentence that
corresponds to the question,
to choose the best answer.
Sometimes, you will see the box number
and nothing else in the sentence.
In this case, the question
will tell you what to do,
such as: consider adding
a sentence at that point.
Other times, you will see underlined text
after the box number.
For these questions,
you'll have to consider
which of four answer
options results in the most
rhetorically effective
expression in the context
of the passage.
Or, which of the four options
results in an expression
that is consistent with the
conventions of standard written
English sentence structure,
usage, or punctuation.
You may see other types of
passage annotation as well.
If the paragraphs of a
passage, or the sentences
in a paragraph are numbered,
one or more questions
will refer to those numbers.
Those questions may ask you, for example,
to consider where a particular
sentence or paragraph
should be placed.
Now, let's talk a little more
about how the questions look.
Some questions that ask
about an underlined portion
of the passage, offer directions
or ask an actual question,
and other don't.
When there are no additional
directions or questions,
assume that you have to choose the option
that's most effective or correct.
If a question includes a no change option,
it will always be the first answer choice.
Choose that one if you
think the original version
presented in the passage,
is the best choice.
Otherwise, pick one of
the three alternatives
offered in the question.
All of the questions on the
Writing and Language Test
are multiple choice, and
are based on the context of
the passages.
So you won't be tested on isolated skills,
or asked to memorize
specific grammar rules.
The questions are designed to ask about
the kinds of revisions and
edits real writers make
to a piece of writing.
They're sorted into two main categories.
Expression of ideas, and
standard English conventions.
Questions that fall into the
expression of ideas category,
focus on the rhetorical elements
of the piece of writing.
In other words, the
questions ask you to improve
the development of the topic,
the organization of information and ideas,
and the effectiveness of language use.
Questions that fall into the
standard English conventions
category, focus on
correcting grammar, usage,
and mechanics problems in the passages.
In other words, these questions
may ask you to recognize
and correct errors in sentence structure,
such as run-ons, or rhetorically
inappropriate fragments,
usage, such as lack of
subject-verb agreement,
and punctuation, such as
punctuating parenthetical element.
If you want to know more about
the Writing and Language Test questions,
you'll be able to see
videos here on Khan Academy,
that go into depth on each question type.
Finally, let's go over how
this section of the SAT
is scored.
The Writing and Language
Test is scored on a scale of
10 to 40.
And that, along with your
score on the reading test,
will contribute to your evidence based
reading and writing score,
which is scored on a scale
of 200 to 800.
When you get your SAT scores,
you'll also see some subscores.
Two of these subscores
are unique to the Writing
and Language Test.
They are: expression of ideas,
and standard English conventions.
You'll get a score of one to 15
in each of these subscore areas.
Some questions of the
Writing and Language Test
will contribute to a words
in context subscore, which,
along with some questions
from the reading test,
will ask you to make
decisions about word choice,
based on the context of the passage
in which the words appear.
Other questions from the
Writing and Language Test
will contribute to command
of evidence subscore,
which, again, along with some questions
from the reading test,
will ask you to interpret,
synthesize, and use evidence
found in a wide range
of sources, including graphics
and a variety of texts.
Both of these subscores will
be on a scale of one to 15.
You'll also see some cross-test scores.
Those will be recorded
on scale of 10 to 40,
and will be based on selective
questions in the Reading,
Writing and Language, and Math Tests.
They'll reflect the application
of reading, writing,
language and math skills
in history and social studies contexts,
and science contexts.
Together, all of these scores
help to build a better,
more detailed picture of your
college and career readiness.
So, that was the introduction
to the Writing and Language Test.
Now, I hope you'll try
working through a few passages
and practice questions, to
get familiar with the SAT.